the movie begins in the year 2065 when
the world is facing severe challenges
like limited resources and various
natural disasters such as tsunamis
tornadoes and climate change during this
period the population of humans is
decreasing rapidly and preventing it is
a major challenge however a government
organization called outer more is
actively working on sending volunteers
into outer space to explore its
suitability for human habitation the
scene then shifts to one of the main
characters a young and beautiful girl
hen who is seen crying in the shower she
expresses her belief that her husband
Junior May no longer be alive and has
been replaced by someone else
simultaneously news reveals that a
significant number of people are being
displaced from Europe and parts of
America are grappling with intense heat
and drought later that night a car
arrives at a house its powerful
headlights Illuminating the surroundings
Junior hen's husband wakes up from the
Sleep noticing the bright lights he then
calls hen and asks her if they are
expecting any visitors initially hen
denies it but that soon changes her
response when Junior starts preparing a
rifle and looking for bullets she
suggests that the visitor might need
help or have lost their way urging her
husband to reconsider and talk to him
before carrying his rifle soon after the
couple decides to open the door and
discovers that the visitor actually came
to meet junior he introduces himself as
Terren a representative from Outer more
the company focused on off-ear
habitation despite Junior having second
thoughts about the guy hen suggests
welcoming him in during their
conversation parents discloses that
Junior has been chosen as one of the
early humans for a space mission to
study the potential for human life
beyond Earth given Junior's background
as a farmer he will explore the
possibility of cultivation in space
however Junior isn't interested in the
opportunity and asks Terren to leave in
response Terren emphasizes that the
couple doesn't have the choice to
decline the offer he explains that the
government has already selected
candidates and Junior must go no matter
what despite this Terren mentions that
the process will take some time giving
the couple about 2 years to spend
quality time together before the mission
after Terren departs Junior heads to the
bedroom when he asks hen if she already
knew teren she refuses to answer and
suggests Junior sleep in the guest room
the husband tries to persuade hen but
she insists on sleeping alone without
protesting any further Junior goes to
the other room and sleeps there the
following morning hen wakes up and
sneaks a peek into a piano stored in the
basement afterward the duo heads to
their respective workplaces hen rides
her bicycle to a restaurant while junior
is seen driving to a meat processing
Factory in the evening after their
respective work is done Junior and hen
meet at their usual hangout spot Junior
asks hen to stop wearing a specific
t-shirt as it holds memories from their
first meeting he does not want the
T-shirt to be ruined as it is very close
to his heart curious hen questions what
else he remembers about that encounter
and Junior responds that both of them
were happy at that time later that night
hen becomes sexually attracted to Junior
she approaches him while he's sleeping
climbing onto him and the two become
intimate afterward hen asks her husband
what he loves most about her Junior
expresses his gratitude for meeting her
during their teenage years considering
himself lucky to have her in his life
the scene then fasts forward a year to a
night of a huge Sandstorm during this
time Terrence pays another visit to
Junior and hen he enters their house and
delivers the news that in compensation
for junior going to space hen will
receive a substantial amount from the
government Terence also mentions that
there are only a couple of weeks left
before he takes Junior which angers the
latter our boy then doubts Terren and
questions why he is the only one
investigating them the officer defends
himself claiming he wants to ensure the
couple's peace Karen adds that he will
stay at their house until Junior departs
to study and collect more details about
him learning that she has limited time
left with her husband hen becomes angry
and starts tossing his belongings around
despite her Outburst Junior manages to
calm her down afterward hen organizes
her clothes in the closet and discovers
a beetle in inside she immediately calls
Junior to inform him but he decides not
to kill the Beetle and lets it go the
next day while at work Junior feels a
sense of longing and rushes to hen
picking her up from her workplace he
takes her to a beautiful location and
the couple enjoys a romantic time
together discussing various topics and
playing suddenly while walking around
Junior notices horses running towards
him in a nearby barn on fire without
thinking twice he rushes to help the
livestock escape the Flames sadly in the
process he gets injured and loses
Consciousness the scene Transitions and
when Junior opens his eyes he finds
himself at home with a fractured hand
tarence is there emphasizing that the
injury won't prevent him from going to
space the officer also mentions that hen
will have an AI companion resembling
Junior while he's away Junior protests
not wanting anyone else to get close to
his wife and expressing his desire to
take care of her the following morning
Terren follows Junior to his workplace
recording the conversation and
surroundings he works in eventually
after a persuasive speech from Terren
Junior agrees to the offer of traveling
to space Upon returning home Terren
places Junior in a chair and runs an
experiment attempting to make him
confess secrets about his relationship
with hen instead Junior becomes enraged
and starts hitting the wall hen hears
the commotion and manages to calm him
down following this the couple can be
seen together discussing doing
meaningful things when Junior returns
from his space trip the scene then
shifts to hen leaving the house with
Terren in a car sadly Junior notices
this and it greatly upsets him our boy
in his distress searches the house and
finds a recording of Terren questioning
hen about the past year with him in the
recording the wife initially expresses
feeling disconnected from Junior but
gradually becoming attached and
accustomed to him later while junior is
outside he notices a group of people
observing him and grabs his shotgun
before pursuing them the mysterious
individuals leaving their SPAC ship
knocking Junior down and inserting a
glowing chip into his neck in the
evening Junior sees Terren and Henry
returning home and secretly enters the
house to Eaves drop on their
conversation parents asks hen how she'll
feel when Junior leaves the next day she
responds that she'll feel lonely as
she's deeply attached to him but plans
to pursue her passion for music and meet
new people to pass the time Junior
listening to this breaks into tears he
cannot stop himself any longer and
bursts into the room accusing Terren of
trying to flirt and steal his wife he
also declares that he's not going to
space anymore and demands Terren to
leave his house immediately despite
terence's attempts to explain and
apologize Junior refuses to listen right
then hen intervenes hugging Junior and
calming him down the next day hen is
seen cutting her hair and preparing for
something special in the evening a
spaceship arrives outside the house
flashing lights all around before
departing a short while later moments
later Junior enters the house he walks
directly to hen hugging her and
expressing how much he missed her he
mentions feeling good to be back holding
his wife in his arms at the same time
Terren appears behind them and guides
the couple to a secret room in this
hidden room the movie's plot unfolds to
everyone's surprise another junior is
present there tied to a controllable
machine it becomes clear that the
recently arrived Junior in the spaceship
is the real one and the one spending
time with hen all this time was an AI
replica the real junior is astonished by
the appearance and behavior of his
robotic counterpart Terence communicates
with the AI Junior revealing that they
placed him in the house when the real
Junior embarked on the space mission the
AI Junior was activated when Terren
turned on his car's headlights that
night although Terren apologizes for the
experiment the AI Junior refuses to
accept it and still believes that he is
the real one he cries out for hen's help
but sadly the latter is in the other
room trying to control her tears it is
clear that she too has fallen in love
with the AI robot and has feelings for
him soon she rushes to the room craing
the AI Junior in her lap and comforting
him however Terren instructs his men to
take hold of hen and escort her outside
so they can euthanize the AI Jun junor
he notes that the lifelike robot has
successfully completed its Mission and
demonstrated exceptional emotional and
loving skills all of a sudden a group of
doctors surrounds the robot
administering a syringe to euthanize him
Junior watches all this with a mix of
amazement and tears in his eyes as the
lifeless body is packed into a vacuum
bag and taken away the next morning hen
helps Junior take a bath as he struggles
with the sudden change in gravity
between space and Earth after freshening
up the couple attempts intimacy but
Junior encounters difficulties leaving
hen disappointed later in the evening
during dinner Junior criticizes hen
accusing her of having an affair with an
AI robot while he was away hen defends
herself claiming that she saw him in the
robot but her husband refuses to believe
her she then apologizes and suggests
starting a new life away from the place
however Junior becomes enraged asserting
that he cannot leave his family house
and farm where his entire family members
are buried he also makes it clear to hen
that there is nothing for her outside
the house as they discuss Heavy Rain
begins outside and hen excitedly rushes
to enjoy it rain is a rare occurrence
and it holds special significance for
hen reminiscent of their wedding day she
encourages Junior to join her in the
rain but he falls to the ground and
becomes enraged he criticizes his wife
for her stupid behavior and storms back
to the house following the incident hen
retreats to the basement to play her
piano and eventually breaks it the next
morning Junior wakes up early only to
discover that hen is not at home he
looks around and finds a letter left for
him unfortunately when he opens the
letter it turns out to be completely
blank junior is left clueless about
where hen has gone and why he spends the
entire day searching for her and
anxiously waits for her return at dinner
time surprisingly a bright light emerges
from outside indicating the arrival and
departure of a spaceship moments later
hen enters the dining room with a smile
on her face greeting Junior she takes a
seat and holds his hand reassuring him
that everything is fine the two then
enjoy dinner together and passionately
become intimate afterward it becomes
evident that the present girl with
Junior is not his actual wife hen but an
AI replica of her despite this
Revelation Junior doesn't seem to mind
he enjoys a drink and dances with her
the movie concludes with a scene of the
real hen traveling alone in an airplane
seeking the purpose of her life